أفادت وزارة الصحة في غزة أن ما
لا يقل عن 20 شخصًا قُتلوا وأصيب
العشرات بجروح في هجوم إسرائيلي
على أشخاص يصطفون للحصول على
المساعدة الإنسانية، وقد تواصلت CNN مع
قوات الدفاع الإسرائيلية للتعليق،
تحذير الآن يحتوي هذا التقرير الصادر عن مراسل CNN، بن
ويدمان، على
صور بيانية  مرة أخرى، الجرحى أو
الممددون على أرضية
مستشفى الشفاء في مدينة غزة ضحايا ما
يقول مسؤول في الدفاع المدني إنه
نيران الدبابات والمدافع الرشاشة الإسرائيلية على حشد من
الناس ينتظرون الحصول على المساعدات
الإنسانية التي هم في أمس الحاجة إليها، وكان
الناس في طريقهم للحصول على الطعام والمساعدات الإنسانية.
الطحين لأنهم ليس لديهم ما يأكلونه، كما
يقول، ثم فجأة ظهرت الدبابات
وبدأت في إطلاق قذائف على الناس محمد
أصيب في اليد والساق،
وضربونا أربع مرات، كما
يقول يوم الأربعاء في نفس المكان،
دوار الكويت في الضواحي الجنوبية لمدينة غزة،
كانت هناك مشاهد  حالة من الذعر
عندما فتحت القوات الإسرائيلية، وفقًا لشهود عيان،
النار أثناء توزيع
المساعدات. وتواصلت شبكة CNN مع
الجيش الإسرائيلي للتعليق، لكنها لم
تتلق ردًا بعد، في
الجنوب، الآلاف
يتدفقون خارجًا من كان يونس حيث
يحتدم القتال العنيف منذ أيام.
يغادرون ولكنهم يمكن أن يصابوا بالصدمة بسبب
ما رأوه وما
فقدوه، وهذه هي المرة الثالثة التي ننتقل فيها،
وتقول إن كل ما تركوه في العالم
مكدس في
عربة التسوق، وهذا أقصى ما يمكنك الوصول إليه
بأمان  من هان يونس بين بحر من
الخيام في البحر، تتوفر بعض الإمدادات،
ما يقرب من 90٪ من سكان
غزة مشردون الآن، ويعيش الكثير منهم الآن
مثل
هذا الشتاء، وقد حولت أمطار الشتاء أجزاء من
هذا المخيم المؤقت إلى بركة موحلة.
يقول أشياءنا إن ما وجدوه هو الغضب من
الرجال الذين يتظاهرون كما يبدو
قادتهم هانيا دعه يرانا
يصرخ هذا الرجل في إشارة إلى
زعيم حماس السياسي الذي يعيش في
الحرب المشتعلة الآن منذ أكثر من
أيام لمدة ثلاثة ونصف  أشهر من
هروبنا يقول أبو دعنا نعود
إلى منازلنا، لقد سئمنا من هذه الحياة،
الموت سيكون أفضل وفقًا
للتوقعات، عاصفة شتوية أخرى قادمة،
بن ويدمان، تقرير سي إن إن من
بيروت